with so many in-person businesses shut  down this past year more and more people  started using  subscription-based box delivery services  you know what i'm talking about blue  apron trunk club is a popular one  yep there are already plenty of these  box delivery companies  but our new sponsor is offering one more  interesting subscription delivery  services are a convenient way  to receive prepared meals groceries  and other products but what if you don't  need anything delivered  yet still want the thrill of receiving a  package introducing boxbox  a brand new box subscription service  that will send you high quality  premium boxes that you're sure to love  every box box is guaranteed to have six  sides and be made of cardboard  or your money back oh sweet  you can set your own box box schedule  with options for monthly  weekly or hourly deliveries see why  people are calling boxbox the number one  boxed box delivery service in the  country  foxbox it's a box